Oh master master what do we do with you
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is just something that I found
myself kind of idly thinking about and
wondering when the master comes back
inevitably cuz look it's not a spoiler
or even really like a theory or a
speculation that the master will
eventually come back of course he will
he always does he's the master we know
he's been in situations where he
supposedly died way more times than this
so just because yo you the master killed
himself or you know the Johnson master
killed Missy in a theoretically enclosed
time loop no the master will still come
back so taking that as a given because
it is and also taking Michelle Gomez at
her word that she is not going to
reprise the role of Missy what do I
think they should do with the next
master because we've now had two
iterations in revived Doctor Who and
we've had well arguably possibly four or
five depending on if you want to count
Big Finish if you want to if you want to
count Eric Roberts but say yes you have
to know that he's been integrating the
Big Finish - and whether or not you want
to count Peter Pratt and Jeffery beavers
separately but in short I would say
there's effectively three versions of
the master from classic who and two from
new who you had the original Roderick
Roger Delgado you had your burnt to a
crisp master played by a couple
different actors and then you had
Anthony Ainley for the remainder of the
classic who run you had Eric Roberts
whatever and then we had John Simm and
then we had Missy so where do we go from
here
so when John Simm took on the part of
the master it was very much a going for
a similar high energy performance to
match Tennant but going psychotic with
it for lack of a better term and I I've
said before I didn't really care for I'd
say about half well maybe less than that
I didn't care for the series three
depiction of John Sims master
I actually liked him a bit better in end
of time and he was fine when he came
back in in series 10 so like he was
solid I never loved him though but he
was you know sort of kind of bouncy kind
of manic he liked they emphasized his
insanity and with Missy they they had an
emphasis on that as well but they kind
of made her more restrained like she
would still she said things that were
consistent with the Johnson master but
they were just slightly more restrained
so like you think of when she killed
Osgood and you know I told you bananas
Shane gone like and I could that's a
line I could totally see Sims master
Julian but it would have been like I
told you like the big goofy like it's
slightly more restrained with her which
I think maybe is a big part of why she
worked better for me than he did but the
emphasis the last couple of iterations
has been on the madness for lack of a
better term with sim kind of embracing
it fully and Missy eventually in the
course of an arc trying to work against
it but it was still very much depicted
as if that was her natural state that
was her nature that she was trying to
change and she was fighting against so
it was still working off the idea that
her base starting level is unhinged and
she's trying to pull it together and do
something different so I think that the
next master we get it's time to do what
I actually
I think in some ways the show has been
afraid to do and even going back into
classic I think it's time to try and
recapture Roger Delgado's master
arguably they kind of do that a little
with derek jacobi who i suppose i should
have mentioned when I mentioned modern
era masters but like you have to go to
Big Finish and the war master series to
really get a taste for that but even
that it's not quite the same thing
because he's going for just sort of a
he's a schemer but he is he is way more
low-key than Delgado was Delgado
Delgado's master first of all as much as
I love Missy and I love derek jacobi and
I can find things to like about the
others
Delgado's the best master he just is
because the determination and the
severity and you believe him when he
tells you that he is going to take over
the world which is why Anthony Ainley
never worked for me Anthony Ainley was
the Saturday morning cartoon version of
that and I couldn't take him seriously
he was never intimidating to me Delgado
was menacing but he also was suave and
he was even keeled and he wasn't insane
or at least none of his behavior was
that really started creeping in as soon
as he unfortunately died an unexpected
death and then initially having the
master be the bird to the burnt to a
crisp master cool look if he's gonna
look like that sure play him kind of
insane
but then Anthony Ainley you know with
the cackling and the kind of stuff that
he would do again they're playing up
that he's mad I think it's time to go
back to a master whose business who
isn't just coming up with a scheme
because it's fun or because he's trying
to prove a point
to the doctor but because it gets him
something that he wants which is power
which is control which is dominance over
other people because not for its own
sake but because he believes the natural
order of the universe is for him to have
that and he is going to execute the
whatever plan he has coldly calculated
ly in order to attain that I think we're
overdue for that master again because
like I said we haven't really had it
since Delgado
not in his pure form there's been
elements of that there's been bits of
that there's been hints of that and
again this is not to knock any of the
other masters I've liked a decent amount
of them but we need to get serious again
it's time it's time to put aside the fun
master it's time to make the master
scary again cuz as much as I love Missy
she's not scary she's unpredictable
that's not the same as scary Delgado
could be scary now who do we cast for
this I have no clue
I don't do fan casting I can't get my
brain to work like that I can come up
with like broad strokes and you you give
you give me names then I can sort of
assess like can do I think they can pull
off what I'm talking about but like
actually coming up with those names in
the first place I have no idea and also
I know I've been saying he the whole
time that's kind of my default because
I'm talking about reviving a version of
the doctor and yell and not literally
I'm not saying we have that you know
regeneration come back but I like
reviving a take and a style on the
master that is rooted in a man playing
it but don't mistake me you could have
this kind of master played by a woman if
that does happen though I am gonna have
one caveat on if the master remains a
woman she shouldn't be called Missy
anymore cuz to my mind Missy is very
specifically Michelle
gomez I it as much as I feel missy is
true to the master and is true to that
character it does feel very much like a
very specific and unique thing to her
not to mention the fact I just think it
would be kind of cool that the master
shows up again is a woman and imagine
the doctor calling her Missy she just
snapped
you know snaps back no call me master
like any of you got and you you got the
right actress to deliver that that could
be chilling so and it could be a woman
it could be a man by all mean I mean the
heck anyoption
go wild but I think the feel and the
vibe what it's time to bring back is the
master who has a plan not because he
can't stop from scheming but because he
has a goal something specific something
that he knows exactly what he's after
and the other thing is if the master
comes back the master I would say the
master actually needs to start smaller
scale and needs to win a few cases the
master needs to best the doctor I don't
mean short-term I don't mean like last
of the Timelords sound of drums where he
beats the mad that beats the doctor
until the doctors plan to overcome him
eventually kicks it no no no I mean like
have some encounters have some skirts is
that the doctor just loses now these
can't be the huge scale you know the
master and acting the big plans thing
but like some just some skirmishes along
the way they encounter each other the
Masters trying to accomplish something
and we know what he what he's doing in
the immediate sense but we don't know of
this part of some master plan but we
just know he's doing this thing and it
can't be good and the doctor doesn't
can't stop it how
some of that reestablish him as somebody
who can best the doctor as somebody that
the doctor and the audience should be
legitimately afraid of that's what I
want to see whenever we get the next
master whether it'll be series 1213
series 18 who knows but at some point
the master will come back this is what I
would like to say what are your thoughts
what do you want to see in the next
master whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's a whole bunch of stuff
to do down there as well cuz buttons
links subscribe likes they helped I
guess um patreon support if you really
like what I do and you want to help make
the show better and all sorts of links
to merch and my social media stuff and
you know what click on some of them the
links will take you places you also
don't have to do because at the end of
the day folks it's you who are the
council and I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]